I've never talked about a dick in my
life okay nothing I didn't pay attention
in fifth grade I think I know what I
know little but I'm confident that it's
intuitive enough to like really figure
it out so those P comes out of it you
think that you're an expert on
everything I am especially the penis I'm
Jewish so this is my bread and butter
you cut something off but there it's for
hygiene purposes as well as to form a
covenant with God I just know that the
foreskin is snipped but I wouldn't feel
confident ever
this guy's circumcised right or mean
that well cuz right I'm not Cena oh
there's no hood but people are against
it now because they think that it takes
away the sensitivity that's bull wait
how do they do it without cutting the
penis I didn't know there was a
difference spermies are the little guys
floating around in semen which is the
fluid that they live in sperm is what
impregnates a woman it's what goes into
the egg this is with tadpole and the
semen is the [ __ ] there's all different
Lee sperm swim in the river of semen
exactly as beautiful as beautiful poetry
a wet dream is when a boy is really
horny in his sleep but he don't know it
and then he wakes up and that's like
boom teens uh they're full of hormones
they're not having as much sex as they
want so they just gotta come in their
sleep oh it's stuck - wake up - yeah
just the whole bunch of senior wonder
guys like wear diapers to bed or
something are you gonna do your dreaming
about some boobs and it's like
effortless masturbation yeah you can
well that's ridiculous I could not know
like feeling enlarged prostate it makes
you have to pee you don't know where the
process for the prostate is that's where
most of the men's like pleasure feeling
is it's like the clitoris of the man
this is how patriarchy hurts men too
because it doesn't allow you to feel the
most pleasure you could feel by having
fingers up your butthole because they
scare you away about being gay I know
men get cancer from it I just know the
exams are uncomfortable if everyone
could just like embrace smashing the
patriarchy men could have really great
orgasms from their buttholes quote me on
that
does the prostate have anything to do
with diabetes No
very aroused male human balls like
they'd like expand or whatever and then
can't finish his excitement my thing is
do your balls actually turn blue
I don't know cuz I'm not gonna look
that's real it's a real discomfort I
don't know if it's true I feel like it's
something a guy made up to get girl feet
of hand jobs why if you're gonna make
something up why would he just get a
[ __ ] from it blue balls are so sad
it's less maintenance I don't like the
idea of having a penis cuz there's like
something between your legs that's just
dangling there I don't need to adjust
all the time the penis is so
uncontrollable doing all kinds of tucks
I'm learning about these tucks up
touchdown sucks I'd really gonna be cool
get a boner though I wish I could like
if we nice not to like have that time at
the bun that's true I have a dream to
write my name in the snow one day I
think you can learn I feel like I'd play
with it all the time I kept it all this
time why don't we have a secret if you
have a penis you have such a secret you
know nobody knows what you're packing
yeah it doesn't really matter yeah
that's like you in a room of people you
always have a secret